so yes I am finished I have a funny
named Marty I'll be talking about
deduplicating document collections using
locality-sensitive hashing the project
is available on github at that address
there's my Twitter account if you want
to tweet with me please do so just
before I start a short introduction a
few words about myself I handed in my
PhD in January I am currently working in
Berlin for a company called comprado
if you would like to move to Berlin we
are looking for developers to people to
join the data science team and finally
I'm also an organizer for pi data Berlin
there's a conference in July so if you
do end up working for come travel in
Berlin you don't lose all this lovely
pilot stuff we have a equally lovely
community in Berlin the tickets were
piloted Berlin went online Friday ok
that's enough about me
so let's get back to the topic law
howard sensitive hashing and since we
are in London let's say that we run a
investment bank that of course uses
fancy NLP technology and pulls in a lot
of content from online various different
sources news articles and blog posts and
financial reports and so on and so on
these are fed into some algorithm magic
AI books that infers what the market is
going to be doing and we make lots of
money now the problem is that our fancy
new algorithm or the crawler rather has
found some number of documents from
various different sources over time and
then we find a new document but because
our algorithm is rather expensive we
want to know if this document is
actually the same as any of these
documents the problem is that in order
to do that
if they're if they're exactly the same
we don't have any problem we can just
hash the two documents or whatever
documents and if the hashes are the same
then the documents are the same the
problem is that if the documents are not
exactly precisely the same on the byte
level then hashing won't do anything for
you if someone has added the name of an
author or a little leading paragraph or
something then the hashes won't match
and you have a problem now you have to
compare the new document with everything
that you have before and then the next
new document again to everything you
have before this is not scalable the
solution is going to be present to you
but before which before that let's sort
of shortly go over where these near
duplicate documents come from so we're
not talking about exact precise
duplicates just documents that are
almost exactly the same but not quite
this is one source editorial correction
so this is an example two different
articles which are exactly the same
article this is from the Reuters corpus
it's about eight hundred thousand
documents collected over a year and you
can see that the article on the left and
the article on the right are actually
the same thing but there's just a few
typos that have been corrected just
enough to make the hashes them different
on the byte level the articles have two
different IDs so they are so from an
identity perspective two separate things
in the data set same thing here you have
various different sort of content
Federation networks online also a
content marketing is nowadays becoming a
thing so this is the original article on
Project Syndicate and notice this
leading paragraph that I've highlighted
in green if you look at the federated
contents or some other publisher has
pulled this article from the original
publishing website
and then done this that leading
paragraph is missing and there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that isn't in the
original one the article itself is
exactly the same it's just that the one
that one paragraph isn't there anymore
and the same applies for things like
content marketing where you have a
company will write a an editorial push
it to their internal CMS content
management system and then from there
it'll be distributed to Reddit and
Slashdot and medium and maybe the New
York Times with tiny little variation so
that it matches the sort of tone of
voice for that particular publication
the content is essentially exactly the
same but there's just slight variations
in the way things are expressed and then
there's the difficult cases like these
this is an example from the from Quora
similar questions data said this was a
casual competition about a year ago what
are the best ways to learn French how do
I learn French genders no is that a
duplicate question is that bi is that
asking the same thing I'm not exactly
sure the locality-sensitive hashing when
it comes to sort of semantic similarity
that's where the locality sensitive
hashing starts to fail because it is
essentially using sort of string level
comparison methods if I have time I'll
talk a little bit more about this at the
end okay so why are duplicate documents
problem well first of all you have
increased storage requirements and with
that comes increased storage costs if
any kind of algorithm you need to run in
your data set that algorithm is going to
take longer to run if you need to move
the data sets around the transfer time
goes up you also have a skewed data
distribution both if you have you have
an incorrect understanding of how many
documents there are in the world if
you're trying to train say a language
model the sort of the
which patterns that you see are going to
be sort of incorrect because of these
duplicated documents you're going to
have a false understanding of how common
certain word pairs are for instance
because they're just duplicated in your
data set if you're training some
supervised classification but also
supervised machine learning models you
can also end up with inconsistent
document labels this actually happened
to us now in the potato Berlin 2018 when
we were putting the program together we
had one author submitted the same
submission the same talked twice with
like I think they removed the company
name from the title for the second
submission and added a sentence or more
explanation of something that's
essentially the same thing one of our
reviewers the same reviewer gave a plus
one for one submission and the minus one
for the other so this is a real problem
and of course also you're have ways that
annotation effort depending a little bit
on how expensive your annotation scheme
is this may or may not be an issue okay
so what do we need we need some document
representation any doesn't matter which
one just some ideally that document
representation would have predictable
space requirements it would be nice to
know sort of roughly speaking if we add
a hundred million documents what is our
database size going to be roughly more
importantly we need then some document
comparison method again some but that
document comparison method should have
scalable computational cost if it scales
exponentially with the number of
documents well then you can't do it
doesn't matter how well you paralyze
you're going to be dead at some point
some possible approaches set similarity
of strings which is what I'm going to be
talking about you can also treat the
duplication deduplication as a
classification task this is what mul
approaches for the kaggle company for
the kragle kora competition where about
you can also do things like try to use
word vectors and do distributional
composition of those vectors and then
try to note embed everything into a
semantic vector space and do nearest
neighbor search the problem is that all
of these including the set similarity
require comparisons between all pairs
but all sort of work through that and
then flip it on its head and then we
don't need all pairs comparison anymore
so what is our document representation
or what is the document representation
that I'm proposing character shingles so
these are just overlapping partially
overlapping sets of characters here's a
function it takes a string here's a
sentence the caps up on the chair or
that's our document and you run it
through the shingling shingling and then
you get these just overlapping sets of
characters
here's another document the cat sat on
the sofa the documents are relatively
similar to each other those are the
shingles for that document and then
we're going to use Jaccard similarity to
compare those two sets with each other
and the similarity for these two sets is
71.4% yay now if we take that approach
and we apply it to the example that you
saw before with an Engram with a
character in ground size six we get a
similarity of about 89% good any
questions yeah
possibly I don't know about that okay so
we can do this and this looks sort of 89
percent similarity seems okay
but we're still doing all pairs
comparisons so how do we get rid of that
locality-sensitive hashing and min
hashing is the answer but in order to
sort of think about how to get that done
we need to go back and think about what
what is it that Jaccard similarity
actually is what is it that we're trying
to model and this is the usual sort of
representation of Jaccard similarity so
we have two sets a and B and then we
have the area where those two sets
overlap it's a set of elements that
those two sets have in common
and Jaccard similarity is just the ratio
between the purple area and then the
combined area of the two or if you are
mathematically inclined that now we're
gonna develop a kind of a stochastic
process that simulates Jaccard
similarity because we don't want to
compute this for all pairs of documents
we would need both documents a and B you
don't want to do that we want some
stochastic process that allows us to do
this but in a probabilistic manner so
we're gonna play a game of darts and the
board here or this Jaccard similarity
visualization is our dartboard and I
will throw darts at the board
my aim is very bad so bad in fact that
it is random and when I throw a dart it
lands somewhere this one happened to
land in the orange area for B it is not
in the overlap for off the two sets so
we'll mark it as a not
lesion we're not going to worry about
what collision means at this point but
we'll just mark it as a not collision
and you're very sort of friendly towards
me so because I didn't sort of my aim is
very bad so I get thrown out the doctor
there's another dart that landed in the
overlap we mark it as a collision and we
keep going and we keep going and we keep
going
and over time we accumulate darts on the
board and collisions and not collisions
and I haven't really done anything
particularly interesting at this point
but I hope we can all agree that if I
keep throwing darts at the board and we
count sort of the ratio between the
collisions and the overall number of
darts thrown that ratio will eventually
converge to the true Jaccard similarity
okay
so now we have a stochastic process that
we can use but we still haven't gotten
rid of the second document so let's go
back to our documents because in the end
we don't actually have darts we have
character shingles here they are
we have document 1 and document 2 it's
just a small sample of the shingles that
you have in both documents some of them
are shared between the two like these
first three here and some of them exist
only in one now we're going to translate
the random process before me throwing
darts at the board into a slightly
different random process that works on
this representation on this data and
that's gonna be a hash function now as
long as our hash function behaves nicely
ie it distributes the hashes that it
gives us nicely across the entire hash
space it'll more or less simulate my
random aim so we'll run one of the
shingles through that through our hash
function and we get back a number 13
then we run all of the shingles
in document 1 through that same hash
function and we now have replaced our
document representation of sets of
shingles with a set of numbers now we're
interested in compressing that
representation we don't want to work
with a set of numbers we just want one
number one number and that number is
going to be the we'll just take whatever
is the lowest value of those hashes that
we got for the document and we'll
replace the entire document
representation with just that lowest
value there we go the lowest value was 7
and then we do the exact same thing with
the exact same hash function the hash
function can be arbitrary any but it has
to be the same for both documents and we
apply the same hash function also to the
second document and we again get some
numbers and because the it is the same
hash function these three will of course
give us the same number but then there
are some shingles that we're not present
in the first document or will hash those
anyway now time for audience
participation what is the probability
that the minimum value for the second
document is the same as the minimum
value for the first document it is equal
to the Jaccard similarity of the two
sets
that's a good question that's the part
that is super difficult to explain so
I'm gonna skip over that so sorry yeah
that's kind of where the dart analogy
fails yes you know in a way yes because
the idea is that that so the random sort
of throwing off the dart is kind of the
same thing as the hash function the
problem is that if you sort of now try
to think about throwing that dart then
like that because the hash function has
to be the same for the two documents but
I can't sort of fix the parameters of me
throwing the dart for the two documents
that like that becomes a little bit
problematic but the idea is that the so
the the hash function sort of just gives
you some whatever number out of each of
the shingles and as long as that hash
function distributes all of all of what
it does nicely across the entire hash
space whether it's a 16-bit or 32-bit
whatever hashed phase then it'll it'll
sort of it'll be kind of similar to that
random process of throwing darts okay so
the probability that that number is the
same for the two documents is it turns
out equal to the Jaccard similarity
there's a few important points here
notice that when we hashed when we
created the hashes for the first
document we don't need the second
document we just we did no knowledge of
any other document needs to exist when
you're creating the hashes for any other
document so you don't need to do
pairs comparisons anymore you just hash
whatever you have in the document and if
the hashes collide well then the
documents are the same okay that's kind
of that's nice but that's just one hash
and it may or may not provide a
collision in this particular case
because the documents are 71% similar
it'll prove it will have a hash
collision with a probability of 71% but
in order to sort of make that entire
process a little bit more robust we
don't just use one arbitrary hash
function we use multiple and we create a
document representation called the
finger called a fingerprint that
contains the minimum hash values or the
lowest hash values over the set over a
over a document for multiple different
hash functions so this is now notice
that this is all the same document this
is all just document one and we have
several different hash functions we
apply each hash function multiple times
to the same document and every single
time we get some different minimum value
out of that set of hashes out of that
set of shingles and that becomes our
document representation then what
happens is we take the so let's say that
there's I don't know a hundred hash
functions that we apply now that hundred
hash functions coming back to the
throwing darts is equal to throwing a
hundred darts obviously the more darts
we throw the closer our approximation is
going to be to the true Jaccard
similarity the similar thing applies
here the more hash functions you apply
the longer your document fingerprint is
the better your chances are going to be
of finding the actual similar documents
that you're
walking for and then there's one sort of
final step which is that you take you
create sort of buckets or bands out of
this out of this fingerprint so let's
say we have 100 hashes and we take ten
bands so we split those hundred hashes
that hundred hundred hash fingerprint
into ten sections and each section we
will now use as an index to a hash table
that hash table is going to contain
document 1 and if any other document
lands in that same sort of key in the
hash table then those two documents are
then considered to be candidate
duplicates the rest is kind of up to you
if you want to compute the actual
correct exact Jaccard similarity of
those candidate duplicates
go ahead this method gives you a kind of
probabilistic guarantee that you will
find similar documents up to some
threshold so the idea with locality
sensitive hashing and and min hashing is
to turn a kind of deterministic
similarity function like Jaccard
similarity into a probabilistic hash
collision there's quite a lot of maths
behind this I haven't invented any of
this there's a very good book by
yunalesca reg called mining massive
datasets that's free available online
and there's a there's a much more
detailed explanation there on how this
works including references I have some
references also in the next slide anyway
so ok so the general process of doing
this is to create document fingerprints
that are these mean hash values of some
length in random mean hash marks
the more you have the better your
chances are at finding those similar
documents you split the fingerprints in
the K buckets documents that land in the
same pocket are then considered to be
candid duplicates the rest is up to you
this is I wrote a library called LS h or
pi LS h if you will this is not yet in
peep installable I wanted to get that
down and by the talk but I didn't you
can install it directly from the github
repo the slow parts are written in sites
and most of it is in Python a friend of
mine told me that he's using it in
production but I'm not sure if you want
to do that quite yet there's a few rough
there's a few rough edges there there's
the this currently just works on an
in-memory dictionary as the backend
database I'm working on a branch at the
moment to sort of include a some kind of
on file data store as well
currently sequel Lite but once that API
is done you can then I don't know use
[ __ ] orcas are or whatever you want
pool requests are very welcome there's
another library this data sketch library
also let's not do that data sketch
library also contains an implementation
of min hash I found it for 3-4 days ago
so I haven't had time to actually look
at how it works it is written all in
Python so it's likely to be a little bit
slower than LSH but the day's schedule
library has a lot more sort of various
different other methods as well in
addition to min hash so it turns out
that the locality sensitive hashing if
you if you swap out min hash which
computes specifically the Jaccard
similarity for a different hash function
you end up getting cosine similarity
this process is again explained in the
mining massive datasets
book so I highly recommend looking at
that chapter three the original paper on
all of this was presented in 97 so this
is by far not a new thing if you want to
look at the if you want to look at the
actor research on this
there's the papers I wrote a blog post
quite a while ago on this particular
method and there's an explanation here
so if you're interested in how you want
how to set the parameters how many
hashes do you want to take and what is
the number of bands that you need to
split those hashes into here's a graph
that shows you if you have a Jaccard
similarity between two sets of say 80
percent and you want an 80% probability
of finding those 80 percent similar
documents well then that's how you need
to set the parameters that's that's
what's quite nice about this method that
it gives you like you don't need to do
parameter search you don't need to learn
any weights or anything like that you
just sort of look at your problem and
you go like hmm this is kind of what I
need to find so this is how I need set
the parameters and then it works if you
want to read more about handling
duplicate questions on Stack Overflow or
the you want to look at the core i
duplicate questions dataset there's
links thank you for listening
[Applause]
great oh thanks so you want to have a
ice cube as many hashing functions as
possible because that's more darts
effectively right but could you get
could you get twice as many darts by
looking at both the min and the max so
even quantiles of the hash that you get
yeah I suppose you good I mean it
doesn't really matter that I mean the
method is called min hash but that's a
kind of an arbitrary thing it doesn't
matter that you take the lowest value in
the set you could just as well take the
maximum value instead and it doesn't it
sort of ends up producing the same thing
but yeah so I suppose you could possibly
I'm not sure about that thank you for
the talk that was a very clear
explanation if min hash what if instead
of taking the main the min I would hatch
all those shingles and put it in their
hashed in a table and then look at
cosine similarity between those those
those shingles like use basically use
use one hash as a signature I'm not sure
okay well you make while you're asking
I'm not using one of those one of those
lines you don't take the mean you store
this line the problem is that you need
to then compare all documents with all
other documents all right that's the
answer of course because you don't so is
the point is that you want something
that will sort of probabilistically give
you a collision okay other questions
laughs yeah how much faster is it than
just doing the stupid Shekar for say
like a Reuters corpus that's really
difficult to say because it completely
it depends on a couple of things it
depends on
what your data looks like like how
similar are the documents that you're
looking for how you set the parameters
so it's also a little bit difficult to
say like obviously if you do all pairs
comparisons just just that's M squared
so you can you definitely know how many
comparisons you need to make but with
this because you sort of get
probabilistic collisions it's a little
bit difficult to estimate exactly how
many comparisons you need to make you
need to look at the parameters and then
sort of try to from those think about
I'm gonna get approximately this many
this many sort of collisions and and
therefore these many comparisons between
documents just like n log N or something
like so have you thought about how would
you evaluate this in terms of efficiency
in terms of effectiveness because you
know there are a lot of academic papers
yeah looking at this they don't consider
like the operational aspect of this
because you want to run this in
production is the are you asking if they
compare or are you asserting that they
don't do that my my understanding is
they don't and as a paper so hold on yes
this finding near duplicate webpage is a
large-scale evaluation of algorithms
actually does exactly that it's a paper
from Google and they look at mean hash
and I forget what the hashing function
is for cosine similarity they compare
how those perform in like a real
production environment given what your
kind of business needs are and then
actually develop a third hashing
function which is a combination of the
two
but yeah sorry though what does that
answer your question or yeah yeah and so
I have actually yeah so there's a few
issues that I didn't mention that you
need to sort of be aware of obviously
this is going to be sensitive to both
the length of the documents but also to
the to the size of the character Engram
that you're using or the size of the
shingle so here you have the same
document or the same pairs of documents
three times but just if you change the
size of the character in Graham you get
very different results out of the
algorithm the same thing is true if you
just add some random data to your
document because this like this doc
these two is the same hair as these two
it's just that the latter two have some
random stuff added to them but because
that random stuff increases the number
of hash as it grows the sets are now
bigger then that changes how the how the
comparisons are the maths end up working
out and you need to be sort of if you
want to apply this to your data set you
need to first look at the data and go
like okay this is sort of the kinds of
similarities that I get for the kinds of
documents that matter to me as
duplicates because it's also not clear
what exactly is a duplicate and what
isn't I mean again if they are the same
on the byte level then yeah okay fine
but if there's just sort of somewhat
similar then it becomes a little bit
more iffy I think I had a few I can't
really read that
[Music]
yes so here's a few examples I guess I
should do this instead I looked at the
Reuters corpus and sort of here's two
documents that are duplicates they're
88% similar and it's like I can't sort
of quickly reading through that find
where the where's the difference maybe
it's just some editorial correction but
then you might you can also end up with
situations for instance in the Reuters
corpus you have lots of kind of
financial reports of just here's what
happened last week in the stock market
and the it's a it's a kind of a
boilerplate article but the numbers in
the data table change but that then ends
up sort of sometimes with this Jaccard
similarity ends up being very very
similar for those or very high for those
those kinds of documents so you need to
be aware of what your data is you can't
just sort of go there you go other
questions yes it's very good talk
is there any mileage in sort of
combining this with some sort of
semantic analysis like Lda to get a
categorization of different documents
yeah and running this only on documents
within the same category yes to reduce
the number of false positives yeah
absolutely you could do that I mean the
main the main purpose of this is to cut
down the number of comparisons that you
need to make it isn't really like the
point isn't really to actually find the
duplicates that's up that still up to
you this is just a way to get to sort of
cut down on the set of documents that
you look at when you have some query
document then you go like well what are
sort of roughly similar documents to
this one are it's not the entire data
set that I need to look at it's just
these ten documents and then you can do
some semantic comparison if you will
but yeah I suppose you can also flip
that around and go like well I'm only
gonna hash the documents that are
already I don't know that have a high
probability on a particular topic for
Lda versus this might be a bit of a
crazy idea but instead of using a
hundred hash functions could you salt
your shingles with some sort of string
and then apply this one hash function
but to like multiple salted strings so
that you get a similar embedding off the
top of my head yes but what would be the
purpose of that that well I suppose I
mean it's like as far as I get like yes
but sort of now thinking about it it
seems to me like it would do the exact
same thing of just having multiple hash
function yes but you could you could you
could have a thousand different salts
and you might not have a thousand
different hash functions yes but that's
why you would dip with that like it's
not I don't I don't see the difference
between the two yeah I guess that there
isn't one other than you use one hash
function instead of one hundred but yeah
I mean hash functions are fairly cheap
yeah so yeah I did so by my intuition on
that would be that instead of like
instead of having a salt that you append
to each string which is gonna be sort of
relatively speaking slow whereas the
hash function is really quick so this is
running holdout how many documents was
that I think that was 500 yeah 500
documents from RSA v1 this is just a
headlight so it's like about a paragraph
of text 500 documents run through 500
documents run through the the
fingerprinting function in the LSH
library over like that's 84 microseconds
that that's really not the part where
you need to be worried about kind of
speed improvement so these so internally
this uses the murmur hash three library
and you can get 32 or 64-bit hashes out
of that depending on how many documents
you have and like how big a hash space
you want but murmur hash is all written
in C and all of the shingling logic here
is also written in seitan which compiles
down to C so like that part is pretty
quick yeah if anyone wants to help me
paralyze the hashing fingerprinting
thing any other questions um it's it's
about lunchtime so if now then go eat
okay thanks a lot
[Applause]